[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بوتا يتحدث اعرفه جيدا منذ التسعينات
رجل اعمال موهوب لكنه ارتكب اخطاء هل من
رساله في خطاب الرئيس الروسي وضربه موجعه
للقوات الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم
وزيلنسكي يظهر سعادته بينما الرد الروسي
لا يتاخر وروسيا تعاقب المانيا واليابان
والاتحاد الاوروبي يقطع امله بالنصر
الاوكراني
فكيف سيكون رد الكريم وصاروخ كان يرفض
مفارقه كوريا الشماليه وثلاث دول عربيه
تنضم الى حلف البريكس في ضربه قويه
لامريكا الاكواس تقول كلمتها الاخيره
بخصوص النيجر وتايوان تتحضر لمواجهه غضب
التنين الصيني
الرحله الاخيره بعد عودته من افريقيا
تناول عشائه الاخير ليلتحق برحلته الاخيره
حيث لقي مصيره هناك مصير جاء متاخرا بعد
خيانته للرئيس الروسي فبوتين لا يقبل
الخيانه ولا يتاخر في الرد عليها ولكن لا
يزال الغموض يكتنف مسيره يافغيني بريجوجل
قائد مجموعه فاغنار العسكريه وذلك بعد
ورود اسمه ضمن قائمه الطائره الخاصه التي
تحطمت في شمال موسكو ليفنا جميع من فيها
وقالت باجنر انه لم يتم العثور على جثه
بريجوجان حتى اللحظه ولكن ذلك لا ينفي
موته ولا يعطي فرصا لنجاته فها هو ميخائيل
بودلياك مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني يقول
كان قد وقع مذكره اعدامه بيده لحظه توقفه
على بعد 200 كيلومتر من موسكو في يونيو
الماضي واضاف بوديلياك ان موسكو بقتلها
للجيش بان اي خيانه سيعاقب عليها بالاعدام
حسب قوله واوضح مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
ان انتفاضه
الذي لا يغفر لاي شخص يجعله خائفا على حد
تعبير بودياك يبدو حديثه مقنع
ا يه خبر المنتظر اخيرا وان لم يكن رسميا
بعد حيث قالت مصادر روسيه انه تم التعرف
على جثه قائد المجموعه فاغناريا في
المشرحه وذلك من قبل احد قاده فاغنار
واضافت المصادر انه استنادا الى العلامات
غير المباشره فان من بين الضحايا على ان
يتم تحديد الامر بدقه عبر الفحص النووي
كما تم التعرف على
مساعد ويده اليمنى وتستمر التحقيقات
الرسميه مع احتمال فرضيه وجود عبوه
الناسفه على متن الطائره واشارت المصادر
الى ان المعلومات الاوليه تشير الى ان
انفجارا وقع في احدى عجلات الطائره في
الهواء ما اسفر عن سقوط احد اجنحتها وها
هو المصدر يتحدث امامكم قالت مصادر روسيه
انه تم التعرف على جثه قائد مجموعه
فاغنريفوجين في المشرحه وذلك من قبل احد
قاده فاجنر واضافت المصادر انه استنادا
الى العلامات
من بين الضحايا اعلن يتم تحديد الامر بدقه
عبر الفحص النووي كما تم التعرف على
وتستمر التحقيقات الرسميه مع عدم استبعاد
فرضيه وجود عبوه ناسفه على متن الطائره
واشارت المصادر الى المعلومات الاوليه
تشير الى الانفجارا وقع في احدى عجلات
الطائره في الهواء ما اسفر عن سقوط احد
اجنحتها ولمتابعه مستجدات حادث مقتل
بريجوجان تابعونا خلال الساعات والايام
القليله القادمه ليخرج الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ويقدم تعازيه لعائله زعيم
مجموعه فاغنار العسكريه
ووعد بوتين باجراء تحقيقات في حادثه مقتله
متوقعا ان تستغرق تلك التحقيقات وقتا
طويلا وقال بوتان ان بريجوجان رجل اعمال
موهوب لكنه ارتكب اخطاء وانا اعرفه منذ
التسعينات واشد بوتين بضحايا طائره من
مجموعه فاغن قائلا انهم قدموا مساهمه
كبيره لا تنسى في الحرب باوكرانيا فهل
تكفي تعزيه بوت للتاكد من نهايه بريكوجان
ومن جهه اخرى هل يعد حديث بوتين رساله
نسول نفسه خيانه موسكو ان نهايته ستكون
مشابهه دعونا ننتقل الى الميدان في
اوكرانيا وللمره الاولى اعلنت قياده
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه انها دمرت مجمعا
للصواريخ الروسيه من نوع اس 400 بالقرب من
قريه
بشبه جزيره القرم ووصف بيان المخابرات
تفجير مجمع الصواريخ بانه ضربه موجعه
للقوات الروسيه لتضيف المخابرات انها نفذت
العمليه بالتعاون مع القوات البحريه شملت
انزالا لجنود في شبه الجزيره وكالعاده
لابد من تاكيد من المصدر كما تشاهدونها
امامكم حيث قالت المخابرات الاوكرانيه
انها نفذت بالتعاون مع القوات البحريه
عمليه خاصه خلالها افراد في شبه جزيره
القرم في التطورات العسكريه ايضا قالت
قياده الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه انها دمرت
مجمعا للصواريخ الروسيه من نوع اس 400
بالقرب من قريه
بشبه جزيره القرمن فيما عب رئيس الاوكراني
فرحته بهذه الضربه مؤكدا ان قوه بلاده
تتقدم ميدانيا الرغم الظروف التي تواجهها
ومتعهدا بانهاء الاحتلال الروسي للقرم
بحسب قوله وفي سياق الضربات الاوكرانيه
ايضا اكد رئيس المخابرات الاوكرانيه تدمر
قاذفتين روسيتين والحاق اضرار بقاذفتين
اخريين خلال استهداف المطارين في موسكو في
المقابل قالت الدفاع الروسيه في تقريرها
اليومي نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه ضربه
مكثفه وناجحه باسلحه عاليه الدقه بعيده
المدى تطلق من البحر والبر لمركز صنع قرار
في القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وذكر تقرير
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها دمرت اكثر من
سته الاف طائره بدون طيار اوكرانيه منذ
بدايه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ومن جهه
اخرى اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ايضا عن اسقاط
طائرتين بدون طيار
فوق مقاطعه بريانسك الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا
واخرى فوق مقاطعه كالوجا المجاوره بينما
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعاتها اسقطت 11 طائره مسيره روسيه من
اصل عشرين هاجمت شرق البلاد وجنوبها 9
منها اسقطت خلال التصدي لهجوم الروسي على
موانئ نهر على موانئ نهر الدانوب جنوبيه
واوضحت ان الهجوم استمر لمده ثلاث ساعات
وخلف اضرارا ماديه في البنيه التحتيه
ومخازن الحبوب وادى الى اندلاع حريق على
مساحه تصل الى نحو ثلاثه الاف متر مربع
دون وقوع اصابات بشريه لكن ومع كل تلك
الضربه الاوكرانيه والرد الروسي العنيف
فقد استبعدت القياده العسكريه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي استرجاع الجيش الاوكراني لاراضيه
الخاضعه لسيطره الجيش الروسي وقالت
القياده الاوروبيه ان الحاليه المتاحه
للقوات الاوكرانيه تجعلنا نشك في قدراتك
على تحقيق اي تقدم كبير جال خبثكم يا
هؤلاء تصرحون بياسكم من جهه ولكنكم لا
تتوقفون عن ضخ الاسلحه فما كل هذا التناقض
ام ان لكم مقارب اخرى وها هي قناه تي في
اثنان تعلن ان النرويج قررت الانضمام
لقافله الدعمنا
وبذلك تصبح النرويج الدوله الثالثه بعد
الدنمارك وهولندا التي تنقل طائره الاف
سته عشر الى اوكرانيا لكن دون تحديد موعد
لهذا الامداد اما قال ان نتيجه الانتخابات
الامريكيه المقبله ستؤثر بشكل جوهري على
دعم واشنطن لكياب مؤكدا انه سيبذل جه
ده مساعدات وبعيدا عن اوكرانيا وحربها
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الروسيس يرجيلا ان
حصول المانيا واليابان على عضويه دائمه في
مجلس الامن الدولي غير مطروح للتداول
مبررا ذلك بانهما لن تجلب اي جديد الى
المناقشات هناك لانهما منفذتان مطيعتان
لاداره واشنطن تماما مثل جميع الدول
الغربيه الاخرى تقريبا
الاحداث والتطورات
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه فشل محاولتها
الثانيه لاطلاق قمر صناعي للاستطلاع مشيره
الى انها ستحاول تنفيذ عمليه اطلاق ثالثه
في اكتوبر المقبل فيما اكدت وكاله انباء
كوريا الشماليه الرسميه بوقوع حادث اثناء
تجربه اطلاق صاروخ فضائي مشيره الى ان
الحادثه غير خطير اعلن رئيس جنوب افريقيا
سيرل راما فوزا ان مجموعه بريكس قررت
توسيع عضويتها بدعوه كل من السعوديه ومصر
والامارات والارجنتين وايران واثيوبيا
للانضمام الى المجموعه في استجابه لدعوات
تسريع اجراءات توسيع المجموعه وتعزيز
دورها في العالم
والى النيجر حيث قال مبعوث ايكواس الى
نيام الرئيس النيجيري السابق عبد السلام
ابو بكر ان المشاوره مع المجلس العسكري
اظهرت ان عوده الرئيس المعزول محمد بازون
للسلطه مستحيله بينما اعلنت الخارجيه
الجزائريه في بيان
ان الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون كلف الامين
العام لوزاره الشؤون الخارجيه لزياره
النيجر في اطار ما وصفه البيانو بالمساعي
الحثيثه والمتواصله للجزائر قصد الاسهام
في ايجاد حل سياسي للازمه في هذا البلد
الجار اعلنت الحكومه في تايوان انها بصدد
سياده انفاقها العسكري خلال العام بقيمه
ثلاثه مليارات دولار لمواجهه التهديدات
الصينيه تاتي هذه الخطوه في ظل غضب صيني
من بيع واشنطن لتايوان اجهزه تتبع تسمح
بمراقبه مقاتلات الصين الحربيه من الجيل
الجديد
[موسيقى]